okay so Arizona is a very interesting
state since the passing of the late john
mccain martha mcsalley was appointed as
senator there
she has never won a campaign but she's
running to keep her seat in November
she's running against or running against
her I think is better the the right way
to say it his Democratic challenger Mark
Kelly Mark Kelly is a former astronaut
twin brother of Scott Kelly who's been a
guest on this program in a new poll out
of Arizona Mark Kelly is ahead of martha
mcsalley by 13 points on an average in
recent polling mark kelly is ahead by 9
points now let's look at prior results
in Arizona in 2012 Republican Jeff Flake
defeated the Democratic challenger
Richard Carmona by 3 in 2016 John McCain
won in Arizona by 13 although admittedly
that the numbers are complicated by the
fact that there was a three-way race the
Green Party candidate got about 6% and
presumably most of that 6% came from the
Democratic candidate so McCain won by 13
could have been more like 7 had there
been no Green Party candidate right now
the Republican incumbent in Arizona is
down by 13 to Mark Kelly so what's
interesting is to look not just at the
Senate numbers in Arizona but also look
at the presidential numbers in the same
poll where Martha McSally is down 13 -
Mark Kelly Joe Biden is ahead of Donald
Trump by 7 in Arizona
52 43 now we want to be careful with
these numbers 50 plus 43 is 93 that
leaves 7 percent either undecided or
third-party a lot of that 7% could break
for Trump and then you would have a real
race in Arizona but it could also
reverse right if the economy does not
improve if the corona virus continues to
run rampant it could go more in Biden's
favor at the same time if November sees
us with a lull in coronavirus maybe
between waves 1 & 2 or with an economy
that is looking better it could end up
looking far better for Donald Trump
these are just bad numbers for Trump
and martha mcsalley today in 2016 Trump
won Arizona by about three and a half so
Biden plus seven is a 10-point swing in
the other direction now why do we care
so much about Arizona Arizona
you know that's relatively small state
it's only 11 electoral votes why does
Arizona matter so much what you have to
understand is that elections rarely go
as 50 completely isolated elections
where what happens in Arizona has
nothing to do with what happens in
Wisconsin or in Michigan for example if
you see a big reversal in one place
often there will be a number of other
places where you will see a move in the
same direction when you look at Trump's
path to victory
all paths to victory reasonably assumed
that he has to hold Arizona and probably
he has to hold Florida Florida is a very
big question mark for Donald Trump right
now particularly with older voters
getting away from Trump and going in the
direction of Joe Biden if Trump doesn't
get Florida Arizona is essentially a
must-win and in just about every
scenario Arizona becomes a must-win in
addition to Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania North Carolina Trump can
win 270 electoral votes without Arizona
but it's really really tough and if
Trump does lose Arizona you have to
imagine it's not just that he loses
Arizona he probably loses something else
from 2016 as well this is why looking at
the Senate race matters so much
Biden plus seven over Trump maybe you
believe it maybe you don't Mark Kelly
plus 13 over incumbent Republican
senator martha mcsalley even if the lead
is only half of that a Democratic
challenger knocking out an incumbent
Republican senator in Arizona by six or
seven which is half of what this last
poll says that does not bode well for
Republicans in general and it would not
bode well for Donald Trump in Arizona as
well really interesting race to look at
and we're going to follow it in 2018 six
out of ten federal offices in Arizona
went to Democrats that could be the
turning point year in Arizona for the
red-blue balance in that state
and of course Mark Kelly is no
progressive hero but he is so much
better than martha mcsalley and it would
be a big win in terms of just their
politics as well monday is Memorial Day
it's the first day off for the David
Pakman show
outside of weekend's in four or five
months we've been going hard with
coronavirus we're just at home so we've
just been working every day we are going
to be taking the day off but running a
huge membership special one-day
membership special if you've been
thinking about supporting the work we do
but the pricing has been dissuading you
Monday we will email everybody on our
mailing lists on our newsletter with a
huge membership discount code very easy
to get on the mailing list just go to
david pakman.com upper right of the
website type in your email address
Monday you will be notified about that
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink it's blink Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka blink east has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video